[Musique]
bonjour écoutez je suis très content
d'être là merci et en fait je suis venu
pour partager avec vous des bonnes
nouvelles
oui enfin alors effectivement je la
première bonne nouvelle elles me
concernent plus particulièrement
j'ai le privilège d'être chercheur je
fais de la recherche fondamentale en
immunologie
vous allez voir pourquoi ça va devenir
important est en fait la bonne nouvelle
dont je viens vous parler
elle est assez peu fréquentes dans deux
domaines qui va nous intéresser
cet après midi parce que le domaine dont
je vais vous parler vous le connaissez
malheureusement ces suites du cancer
donc le cancer c'est une maladie
terrible c'est une maladie ce serait
encore une fois très surpris que et
personnes oui il ya certains d'entre
vous qui n'est pas été directement ou
indirectement confrontés à ces
pathologies et vous le savez que ces
pathologies non seulement elles sont
douloureuses pénible et quelquefois très
sévères dans leurs pronostics
mais les traitements qui les
accompagnent ne sont pas dénués
eux-mêmes de toxicité ces traitements
les connaissent et la chirurgie c'est la
radiothérapie et c'est la chimiothérapie
et dans tous les cas ce qu'on essaye de
faire avec ces traitements
c'est d'enlever la tumeur c'est très
intuitif
ça fait du sens comme on dit aux
canadiens il ya une tumeur on essaie de
l'en v est en fait que je vais essayer
de vous transmettre aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il existe une révolution
thérapeutique qui existe
dès aujourd'hui et qui permet de
proposer de nouveaux traitements pour ce
cancer pour ces cancers
en fait pour vous accompagner dans la
compréhension ce nouveau traitement
je vais vous parler d'immunologie or
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une mine au logis
l'immunologie c'est la science qui
essaye de comprendre l'immunité
alors qu'est ce que c'est que l'immunité
mais l'immunité c'est l'ensemble des
mécanismes qui nous permettent de lutter
contre tout un tas d'agression auquel on
est soumis constament par exemple en ce
moment j'entends quelqu'un qui tous par
exemple en ce moment même dans cette
salle deuxième merci nous sommes en
train de lutter contre 2,3 maladie
virale de trois maladies bactériennes un
début une maladie parasitaire
mais rassurez vous serez bien se passer
et ça va bien se passer parce que vous
avez un système immunitaire qui
fonctionne et vous savez le système
unitaire
il ressemble à beaucoup de choses très
importantes dans la vie c'est toutes ces
choses dont on s'aperçoit qu'elles sont
justes essentiel à nous même quand elles
ont disparu
et vous savez dans mon domaine qui est
celui de la médecine la clinique met
tout le monde d'accord dans la recherche
puis vers des interprétations un peu
compliqué un peu acrobatique quelques
fois mais la clinique elle met tout le
monde d'accord et la démonstration de
l'importance de l'immunité dans le fait
qu'on ne puisse vivre dans le monde qui
est le nôtre
elle est donnée par des maladies
génétiques par la clinique
vous avez tous entendu parler des bébés
bulles de ses bébés qui ont des systèmes
immunitaire déficient
parce qu'ils ont un gène qui n'est pas
exactement conforme aux gènes que l'on a
dans l'espèce est en fait cette
immunodéficience leur interdit de sortir
de leur bulle parce qu'ils vont être
vulnérable à l'ensemble des maladies
microbiennes qui nous entoure donc moi
encore une fois j'ai le privilège
d'essayer de comprendre au niveau le
plus fondamental les mécanismes qui nous
permettent d'avoir un système unitaire
qui fonctionne alors si ces militaires
cancer comment ça se passe eh bien c'est
ce que je vais vous expliquer mais ce
que je suis venu avec ce sont des
illustrations des diapos pour que vous
nous croyez pour que quand je vous dis
que c'est une révolution c'est avec le
nom de révolution est très galvaudé à
l'heure actuelle on parle de révolution
par exemple quand on passe du petit
iphone aux moyens iphone moi je ne parle
pas de ça je parle d'un jalon dans
l'histoire de la médecine même dans
l'histoire de l'humanité qui fait qu on
a passé une étape et qui avant et il ya
après donc c'est ça dont on va parler et
donc je vais vous montrer des preuves
parce que je suis un scientifique
donc je crois les données vous savez les
données sont têtus quand même
donc il s'agit ici d'un cancer de la
peau qu'on appelle un
un mélanome et c'est un cancer qu'on
appelait avant cancer généralisé vous
savez en fait c'est un cancer qui est
métastatique c'est à dire que les
cellules cancéreuses sont allés ailleurs
coloniser d'autres tissus comme la le
foie et vous voyez ici une métastase au
niveau hépatique
comme je vous l'aï dit la plupart de ces
pathologies et vous le savez elles sont
malheureusement trop souvent en
échappement par rapport aux traitements
qui sont proposées et en plus ces
traitements ont des effets secondaires
qui sont non négligeables
c'est le cas pour cette patiente et vous
pouvez en juger par vous même
elle a échappé aux traitements et vous
avez vous pouvez voir ici donc une
expansion assez considérable de la
tumeur primaire qui s'accompagne aussi
d'une aggravation de la métastases
hépatiques
il se trouve que ces patients qui sont
en échec thérapeutique
ils peuvent rentrer dans des essais
cliniques et les essais cliniques là
sont des essais de ce que je suis venu
pour partager avec vous c'est à dire la
reprogrammation du système immunitaire
de nos propres défenses et militaires
afin de lutter contre ces pathologies du
moral et le résultat est là
c'est à dire que vous voyez ici déjà une
belle diminution de la métastases
hépatiques et puis surtout un jour et
cette patiente elle se rappelle de ce
jour un jour il s'est réveillé et sa
tumeur était morte à côté d'elle c'était
la tumeur inquiéter morte bien
évidemment et vous pouvez voir donc le
résultat ici et aussi ça s'accompagne
d'une disparition de la métastases
hépatiques
ça c'est une vraie révolution c'est une
révolution thérapeutique
[Applaudissements]
alors maintenant on va essayer de
comprendre ensemble comment ça marche
et la bonne nouvelle c'est très intuitif
très facile à comprendre
mais il ya aussi une autre bonne
nouvelle derrière et je vous la garde
pour la fin mais il faut vous soyez
attentifs donc ce qu'on a essayé de
faire et quand je dis on s'est
collectivement en fête ses 40 ans
quatre décennies de recherche en
immunologie purement fondamentale ce
qu'on a essayé de savoir c'est comment
s'organiser la réponse immunitaire
donc la réponse immunitaire on peut leur
on peut l'observer on peut la disséquer
on essaie de la comprendre à plusieurs
échelles la première échelle celle de
l'organisme
donc là l'échelle d'observation c'est le
m quand on travaille dans les modèles de
souris ça peut être le cm à dire le le
100e de m mais quand on comprend un peu
l'anatomie du système immunitaire
ensuite on peut essayer de s'intéresser
à une autre échelle c'est à dire les
chefs des cellules qui sont vraiment à
l'action dans cette réponse immunitaire
si par exemple une cellule tumorale mais
on découvre qu'à des cellules comme des
lymphocytes par exemple mais qui peuvent
éventuellement reconnaître ces cellules
tumorales on est vraiment à cette
échelle-là l'échelle c'est le micro m
c'est le millionième de mètre
ios4 fabuleux dans le métier que je fais
c'est qu'on peut essayer aussi de
comprendre à une échelle encore plus
petite
c'est à dire l'échelle 3 log en dessous
du millionième de mètre c'est à dire le
nanomètre et là on est un milliardième
de mètre et on s'aperçoit qu'en fait les
cellules du système immunitaire sont et
sont équipées de récepteurs de
récepteurs comme vous voyez ici l'un un
récepteur activateur en verre qui est
une molécule qui va permettre aux
lymphocytes donc là cellules du système
immunitaire de dialoguer avec
l'extérieur et là en l'occurrence avec
la cellule tumorale est donc une étape
absolument importante dans ce que
j'essaye de vous transmettre aujourd'hui
ça a été de s'apercevoir qu'ils avaient
en fait deux types de récepteurs des
récepteurs activateur on va dire ce sont
des accélérateurs et puis des récepteurs
inhibiteur on va dire que ce sont des
freins est en fait pour filer la
métaphore on va dire que la cellule d'en
face dans l'occurrence à cellules
tumorales
elle va pouvoir agir sur cet
accélérateur sur ces récepteurs
activateur les espèces de
pied moléculaire et puis d'un autre côté
elle va pouvoir aussi agir sur les
freins avec un autre pied moléculaire et
donc vous voyez que la manière dont le
lymphocyte va pouvoir réagir quand il va
rencontrer une cellule tumorale
ça va être fonction du niveau
d'activation cavale recevoir de
l'accélération ou d'inhibition autre
point maintenant extrêmement important
dans la démonstration mais je trouve que
le système unitaire il n'est pas
simplement bon à éliminer des
pathologies microbienne virales
bactériennes parasitaires et d'aussi
très bon et des mines et des cellules
tumorales
il a été sélectionné depuis à peu près
500 millions d'années pour lutter contre
tous un système de défense multicartes
nous défend en ce moment-même aussi
contre des débuts de tumeurs rassurez
vous ça va bien se passer
ok mais alors si le système immunitaire
est si performant qu'on sait que des
cancers bas et c'est ça qui était très
important c'est de s'apercevoir que
quand il y à une cellule tumorale quand
il ya un environnement tumorales il y à
beaucoup plus de signaux inhibiteur qui
sont données qui sont transmis au
système unitaire de manière générale
c'est comme si la cellule y tumorales
elle appuyait plus sur le frein que sur
l'accélérateur et donc on a un système
dans lequel le séminaire est là mais en
fait il est endormi un peu comme la
belle au bois dormant
donc la belle au bois dormant tant
qu'elle n'est pas réveillé et sert pas à
grand chose alors on va arrêter
l'exemple à ce stade
autre élément de la démonstration qui
est très important maintenant qu'on sait
tout ça maintenant que on a donc
disséqué système immunitaire encore une
fois de manière purement fondamentale
est-ce qu'on peut avoir l'ambition de
transformer ses résultats fondamentaux
en démarche thérapeutique est ce qu'on
peut faire ce qu'on appelle de la
recherche translationnelle
est-ce qu'on peut traduire ces résultats
fondamentaux en thérapie et bien encore
une fois c'est très intuitif
la réponse avait bien bien bien sûr oui
et comment on pourrait faire on pourrait
faire en essayant de couper les freins
de lâcher les freins et ça on peut le
faire parce que on a la chance d'avoir
des anticorps les anticorps encore une
fois on en a tous s'est passé antique or
là dont je parle
il se trouve que et j'ai pas le temps de
vous raconter l'histoire vient de gens
meurent dans vie c'est que les anticorps
qu'on a tous dans notre corps en fait on
sait les faire à l'extérieur on sait les
faire dans des usines à faire des
anticorps c'est un processus qui est
totalement maîtrisé au niveau industriel
on peut faire des kilogrammes
d'anticorps et ce qui est génial
la beauté en fait de l'anticorps elle
réside dans le fait que cette molécule
elle est extrêmement spécifique de ce
que de ce qu'elle reconnaît en fait
l'anticorps il va pouvoir cibler une
molécule et pas une autre
par exemple donc on va pouvoir générer
des anticorps
du point de vue industriel encore une
fois au niveau industriel qui vont
reconnaître soit les récepteurs
activateur soit les récepteurs
inhibiteur évidemment ce qu'on va faire
dans notre cas dans le cas du cancer
on va vouloir réveiller la belle au bois
dormant on va vouloir donc lâcher les
freins
on va donc faire un anticorps de telle
manière qu'ils puissent bloquer les
récepteurs inhibiteur et ainsi réveillé
le système immunitaire endormi et bien
le résultat
vous l'avez vu c'est le résultat
clinique que je vous ai montré c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui on est arrivés par
une recherche purement fondamentale qui
n'a jamais été guidés par le désir de
soigner le cancer qui a juste été guidé
par la curiosité qui fait que l'homme
est homme et qu'il envie de comprendre
le monde
dans lequel il vit et nous biologistes
on essaye de comprendre le monde vivent
plutôt que le reste de l'univers et bien
grâce à ses recherches fondamentales
on a pu mettre en évidence l'ensemble de
ses processus est passé de cette
connaissance à la génération de nouveaux
médicaments
alors ces médicaments encore une fois
ils existent ils sont déjà en cliniques
disponibles pour certains d'entre eux et
les autres sont en essai clinique et on
assiste à une révolution je les ai déjà
dit mais est ce mot a déjà été utilisé
dans les présentations précédentes on a
on assiste vraiment une rupture de
paradigme c'est à dire que c'est un
moment dans l'histoire de l'humanité qui
est un moment irréversible dans lequel
un champ là celui de la cancérologie et
a été déviée il reste bien évidemment
les traitements dont certains marchent
très bien qui consiste en chimiothérapie
radiothérapie et chirurgie aussi mais il
y a un autre champ qui est apparue et
donc l'ensemble du champ ceux des vies
maintenant vers ce qu'on appelle locaux
immunologie c'est carrément une nouvelle
science qui est apparue et toutes ces
découvertes
en fait elles ont du point de vue
clinique même pas 10 ans d'ancienneté et
ce qui est absolument incroyable c'est
que l'ensemble de ces découvertes est un
pur produit de la recherche fondamentale
et c'était ça mon autre bonne nouvelle
l'autre bonne nouvelle donc c'est de
dire que la recherche fondamentale et
juste fondamental c'est elle qui est la
source des révolutions aujourd'hui
qu'ils peuvent prendre en charge ces
traitements et c'est ça que je voulais
partager avec vous et j'espère que vous
êtes aussi fasciné par le vivant aussi
émerveillés par les découvertes de la
recherche et la prise en charge des
cancers merci beaucoup pour votre
réponse
[Applaudissements]